hello teachers I'm Megan welcome to
confer educators initial course for
teachers on Khan Academy you are about
to begin an exciting learning journey
but first let's look together at the
path that lies ahead
to get started click the start training
button to begin learning this course has
one unit composed of seven lessons in
which we explore everything from getting
started on Khan Academy to classroom
implementation and diving deeper into
Khan Academy's teacher reports the
course begins with a lesson getting to
know Khan Academy which shares a little
about our commitment to high quality
education and a learning experience we
hope to provide then we have the lessons
setting up your teacher account which
covers the main teacher functions
setting up classes an overview of Khan
Academy content and a walkthrough of the
student experience the third lesson
introduction to mastery learning
provides a broad overview of mastery
learning and addresses frequently asked
questions related to mastery learning
the fourth lesson using course mastery
on Khan Academy dives deeper into Khan
Academy's mastery learning system this
lesson includes a closer look at Khan
Academy's progress reports and showcases
teacher insights on using progress data
with students lesson 5 using assignments
to support mastery learning details how
to create and manage student assignments
on how to leverage Khan Academy's
assignment reports to support mastery
learning with students lesson 6 focuses
on implementing Khan Academy with
students in this lesson we go further
into the logistics of using Khan Academy
with students including our recommended
implementation model classroom best
practices and student motivation in
lesson 7 teaching remotely with Khan
Academy we explore implementation
recommendations and tips for teaching
students beyond the walls of your
classroom these resources are designed
to support teachers and students in
remote learning experiences using Khan
Academy and other educational tools the
course concludes with the next steps
section that explores the different
opportunities for further education so
you can continue to learn and innovate
in your classes confer educators was
designed so teachers coaches
administrators could experience Khan
Academy as students so in order to
complete the course you'll need to
engage with exercises master skills and
perform well on the final assessment but
don't worry there's a reward for those
who complete this journey your
professional learning is in your hands
start confers initial course right now
and find out how Khan Academy can expand
the possibilities in your classroom do
you have any questions about the course
access the Help Center for additional
support see you soon